coming up next and my ex-husband was
like I don't like you using that
language
and I stopped but a lot of women waste
their 20s and then they get to this age
and then they're scrambling and you see
that Panic I'm a little bit all over the
place and just being Mindful and taking
the steps to change because we were
trying to find some but I was having a
hard time finding some that weren't like
a grand foreign
the swearing the swear I try to tackle
one thing at a time good because I get
overwhelmed if I go after like too many
things at once so my steps is right now
cooking okay the next thing is fashion
okay he's coming okay I'm not gonna lie
the swearing is gonna be last because I
put I just like that hey hey you know
what all I'm saying do you you know
share your body count drop the f-bombs
it's just okay we're not gonna
it's just every now and then a good
F-bomb I understand but it's gonna it's
gonna go it's gonna go I mean you can
say it in you know a company of people
that you trust but when you say it to
random strangers they're like man Pearl
has a potty mouth and you just would
hate for people to have that as a first
impression one in all seriousness y'all
I mean the only reason I mean Pearl is
absolutely completely genuine and super
sweet and I am so grateful to be here
and I'm not you know blowing smoke but
um I remember I I'm sharing this with
you because I had to go through that and
my ex-husband was like I don't like you
using that language
and I stopped so and you take you take
feedback really really well so that's
one of those things that once you're
already kind of mindful of it it's like
yeah I know I do that I need to stop as
opposed to
we can film here
[Laughter]
that's it but you've um the fact that
you are aware the fact that you are
trying and you are moving with intention
is huge especially at your age because a
lot of women waste their 20s I was
married at 25 but a lot of women waste
their 20s and then they get to this age
and then they're scrambling and you see
that Panic so I'm really proud of you
that you're being mindful of what you
can get better at no none of the stuff
you said surprises me okay that's always
like the feedback I could you know
because most of the stuff I sort of have
plans like to to work on you know but I
have to do one at a time otherwise I get
overwhelmed no I agree with you one at a
time is good one at a time is good you
have a goal you're getting incrementally
better and that's fine you don't have to
be perfect how did you work on the
scatter brain thing
uh okay so with the communication
um
so some of the work that I do has a lot
of communication and then going to
graduate school and having to present
and just always thinking about what I'm
saying how the audience is going to
receive it and that audience could be
work people or it could be you know my
guy or it could be my children and I'm
not perfect at it but I try to think of
the end in mind so at the end of this
talk what do I want you to take away
with that take away from that and then I
try to walk it back honestly a lot of it
comes with maturity too so don't put too
much pressure on yourself I mean you're
26 right I'm 47 so it's totally fine but
just being mindful of it another big
thing what you do here with YouTube
That's helped me a lot having a YouTube
channel uh being in Zoom meetings I've
taken a lot of etiquette and elegance
classes so I've had to invest in making
sure that I show up a certain way
getting that feedback seeing yourself
recording yourself and saying wow
I'm a little bit all over the place and
just being Mindful and taking the steps
to change where did you take etiquette
classes because we were trying to find
some but I was having a hard time
finding some that weren't like I'm like
five grand for etiquette they they are
expensive it is an investment and
actually I heard of one from Kevin
Samuels so I did Anna Bay signature
program I've done Emma Dupont signature
program
um oh goodness business communication
um actually I'm enrolled in her
International etiquette course but it's
kind of like you go down a rabbit hole
I've done um Jamila musaeva's uh
programs I bought her uh programs for me
I can nerd out on this stuff because I
really like it because again as a boy
mom with no sisters working in a
masculine environment I have to be very
mindful that doesn't come on me because
you can start
acting like a dude because that's what
you're around all the time and so I'm
just very intentional about watching how
men behave and doing the opposite so no
I think that's something that's
definitely rubbed off on me just because
just because I grew up between so I was
I grew up with sex I have 10 total but I
was yeah it's it's kind of a long story
out my mom gave up one kid for adoption
when she was 17. so it's the same
parents but they just started five years
later like they were young and then
three we adopted as teenagers so I
didn't grow up with four of them wow so
that yeah they adopted like three 15
year olds but they were you can speak to
the blended family wow yeah but it was
um like two came after I left for
college and one came when I was a year
old
you see so and she had moved out when I
was I think she moved out when I was two
or something so oh wow yeah I was I
think she might have come before I was
so young but when I was in the house
there was six does that make sense it
does there was no blended it was just me
and my sibling gotcha okay I grew up
between two boys
mm-hmm so and my next youngest sister
was five years younger than me and we
just did it we didn't really get along
when we were younger so
um it was kind of like I was just
friends with the boys and then you're
playing volleyball which is around girls
but it's not really a feminine
environment right right
um and same with basketball and like
track you know I mean you're around
girls but it's really not conducive for
like femininity right right and then
when I worked I was in corporate I was
also I was the only girl at the office
yeah so I definitely can see how that
stuff can rub off on you because there's
definitely like
stuff that like in terms of being girly
I just get frustrated because I'm like
they're like oh it's so nice you don't
wear a lot of makeup I even had someone
accuse me of like not so funny he said I
um I don't do my hair and makeup because
of my brand and like I have to come off
as like the girl next door who just
doesn't know and I was thinking of like
I wish I knew how to curl my hair I wish
I knew how to do makeup I'm like I just
genuinely don't know how to do it and so
like a lot of times I would just get
super frustrated because I would try to
be like this is so bad yeah well don't
beat yourself up about it I mean one of
the things that I understand you with
the sports you know there's a good side
of that competition but just knowing
that being competitive you know is a
little bit masculine so you just have to
kind of work to offset it if that's
something you want to do when it comes
to that beauty routine
um one of the things that I would do
when I would have someone do my hair or
makeup I would ask them teach me show me
what you do sometimes we just sit in the
chair oh I love it and we go because you
know like we talked about that
maintenance with the nails and the
eyelashes and all that I have to be able
to do it myself you know I wear very
light makeup I do like a red lip some
mascara and that's it like I'm not
contouring I put red polish on when it
chips I get it repainted that's pretty
much my signature look and it's
something that I can do on my own so you
start small and you find something that
you can maintain and find something that
your guy likes and you just go with that
so you don't have to act like you're
going to be on the runway just you know
incremental progress
the
okay we got the marriages let's you
ready to watch some Kevin Sam let's do
it watch them Kevin oh dear so what I'm
good at is I'm coachable you are my
cooking is coming yes you fed the the
crew yesterday I actually feed them a
decent amount I feel like it's good
practice that's really good practice
having them around so I'll just like it
depends on the day because sometimes
it's like I'll run out of food too quick
but
um I I do give them food a lot because
I'm like I get feedback and I can see
what is good and what isn't and so it's
kind of like a family you know so it
sort of is good practice that's another
thing you do really well at you actually
seek out feedback because I noticed
y'all yesterday when Pearl was cooking
and she made a whole like day's worth of
food she asked everybody after they ate
okay rate me on a scale of one to ten
and she had some really high marks but
even if it was nine or nine point five
she's like what do I need to do to make
it a 10 I was like whoa
Pearl wants that perfect score and
that's a good thing you know that that
try that want to that drive I think
that's good
oh what should
we watch let's see actually I'm gonna go
over this really quick okay because just
I'm gonna go over with the audience okay
guys
um this is what we put together okay
just if you guys were not here I'm just
gonna show you so this is what women
should have on their wife resume meal
prep or cooking experience
babysitting or love for children
ability to manage money or stick to a
budget
family relationships so what kind of
family do you guys want and are you on
the same page who is your family were
your parents married do you have an
example small or big nuclear family do
you think um when looking for I
shouldn't say looking when when you know
vetting suitors
um do you think it's good to like
because I always try if I can too I
think it's good to finish the sentence
oh sorry do you think it's good to look
at their family structure to see if like
they had a two-parent home and if they
or if they'd had marriage experience
absolutely long-term relationship
experience absolutely this is a wife
resume but I think wives should not only
be ready to discuss this for themselves
but these are the questions that we have
to ask I mean I love love and I know
sometimes we get in that feeling and
it's just like everything they do is
wonderful but if their mom is a battle
ax you need to know that you're signing
up for that and is he going to protect
you or is he going to leave you exposed
it's so much much I've never thought
about that that's crazy I've thought
about the two parent home but I've never
thought about how does their because
moms with sons can overtimes be
overbearing yeah and wow I've never
thought of that I've had that experience
I mean being the daughter-in-law you
know I I want to be you know accepted
into the family and it's hard if that
doesn't happen and especially if it's
nothing that you did that's just how she
is you know that can be devastating so
you need to know how is your husband
gonna handle that you know I know we
always talk about you know Mama's Boys
or whatever but we are assuming or I am
assuming that you're dealing with the
caliber of man that is ready to be a
husband so you need to know what you're
getting yourself into we have to Choose
Wisely and that properly and just
because we feel good with someone that
doesn't mean he's going to be a great
husband
um but yeah that's that's important to
know
um you're gonna spend holidays together
you're going to do like family
Traditions you know weddings and births
and funeral like you need to know when
when these two groups come together what
is that experience going to be like and
I have one more that I can already hear
my mom saying I didn't talk about faith
yeah yeah thanks Mom but yeah it's
important and it's not about you know
I'm a Believer
um and I do I am a Christian and that's
important to me but it has to be
something that
um you all are on the same page about
you know I go to church every Sunday if
he doesn't am I okay with that if it's
just like you know what this is the way
that I worship you don't have to go
that's fine but if it's you know the
other way around if he's active in the
church and you just want to sit at home
you know that could cause an issue so
whatever it is um that's something you
need to be ready to talk about that's I
I was just thinking about this the other
day because I grew up Catholic and then
I went to the Christian church for a
couple years and then I moved to England
and I got really overwhelmed and I just
kind of stopped going the last I don't
know a year or two maybe two years and I
was trying to think like what do I want
to do now you know because now I have
you know stuff has been outsourced like
other people are doing shows I have a
bit more time than I did like last year
and it's
it's a good question like what would I
want my kids to be raised as absolutely
and it wasn't that important to me when
I was younger I was kind of oh catholic
christian like as long as there's
something it's okay but there's
something in me I think that would be
sad if my kids didn't go to Catholic
school I was thinking about this the
other day that's important and so that's
something that you'd have to talk about
I grew up with youth group and vacation
bible school and singing in the choir we
talked about music yesterday I love like
the praise and worship like there's
always music in my head and in my home
like am I gonna be okay with someone
who's like shut that off you know stop
so it's something that you have to talk
about because believe me when the kids
come then you really know like who you
have hitched Your Wagon to
Fitness are you in shape what's your
Fitness routine yeah how do you handle
constructive criticism or feedback sex
drives communication social media yeah
um can you go over the list that you
made up the other day about women in
high value men
what list did I make the other day
let me
but oh friend groups I'm gonna finish
this I'm trying to finish this thought
yeah good friend friend group who's
gonna be in your circle and share
um that in your spouse girls trips how
much do you drink do you smoke Etc and
what is the relationship with the
co-parent
um okay so go that looks pretty thorough
that's a lot oh I just I have so many
notes
um are these the coffee pots sometimes
this is I think this is it what men dog
do you mean this one
so I wrote this list about so I grew up
in I would say upper middle class and we
know a decent amount of I would say like
top 10 men that's pretty common
um and I just wrote a list about like
what those men look for where I'm from I
know this is different a lot of people
would argue with me and say that but
this is just you know white suburban
community this is what yeah and I would
argue we'll go through this list I would
argue in any Community if you have a one
percent kind of man a lot of this stuff
is going to hit so I put
sometimes put it like this absolutely
um no tattoos yeah my mom and honestly
this my mom told me not to date guys
with tattoos either
um I think men can get away with it more
um but for the women
um Hobbies every weekend cannot be going
to the bar and looking like a hoe
well that's pretty clear yeah I agree
that's in line with what we talked about
you know what are your uh friend group
and what do you like to how do you turn
up no have you made makeup eyelash
extensions no my brothers hate super
heavy makeup absolutely no heavy
eyeliner no shopping addiction like the
way the my brothers even if they make a
lot of money they still look at you as
like an expense and if stuff goes south
then maybe you don't have a lot of money
are they still gonna have to pay
absolutely men look at everything as an
expense not just the woman the car the
vacation the house the private school
for the kids everything is a line item
that's just how they think so keeping
that in mind not only is it um costly
but also when you have all that stuff on
and you look like a
Runway a Broadway actor who is
complimenting you your girls
or the man that you want
it's often the men they don't want
because like that look that I have I
have a friend that like dresses like
like that you know
um and it's just like yeah like men
approach you but it's not the type of
men you want to be approached right what
are they approaching you for yeah you
know
um
so I put no piercings except ears
exactly so like belly button rings no
like the nose rings no
um and even the ears like none of this
up here it has to be you can do the
double or the even the triple um but you
can't really further than that no
um you have to get ready in 30 minutes
or less because otherwise it's like if
we want to go somewhere and it's quick
like you you can't have this long
extensive routine exactly and that ties
back to what we said about all of that
elaborate makeup and it ties back to
um having your capsule wardrobe or
having your clothes that okay this is my
I wear what I describe as being ready
from like the carpool to the kitchen and
then you know also because I work remote
and I'm in Zoom meetings a lot I always
make sure that I'm presentable I know
sometimes people are like oh I'm just
running to the store but you never know
who you run into and a lot of things a
lot of times women don't think about men
are always watching and they see you
from across the way and they may decide
to approach or not based on what they
saw you're you're making me want to
dress better
you do a really good job I've seen you
with and not a lot but I've seen you
with like more of a blouse on instead of
Niagara Falls I don't even know Pearl
it's like
okay this thing
um I've seen you wear blouses I've seen
you kind of curl your hair I do it for
the show like to me that's that should
do it for your man the show I know I'm
at like like okay I always think this is
like a behind the scenes versus that
with a million subscribers this is
you're right you're right you're right
I'm gonna I'm gonna improve Okay add it
to the list one thing at a time
um other thing no super long fingernails
you can get the fake ones but they have
to be like short like they can't I've
seen like women like their wives might
get them up to here but like it's it's
it's very usually French nothing too
crazy yes and I mean that is one of the
things that we you know learned about in
Etiquette and elegance classes they're
just some things that look
um more refined and there are some
things that look a little trashy I'm not
judging anybody but there's a reason
they call a certain manicure an active
length because
when a man is choosing you he's choosing
you for how you are going to be helpful
to him
I know we make an emotional decision but
a man can have an emotional experience
and then move on if you are not useful
to him Kevin talked about that wow
that's so interesting Kevin talked about
that a lot so there's so many facets of
that but when it comes to the nails not
only is it is it an expense and then
it's going to take time away because you
got to get them you know done I'm all
for a beauty routine I love you know
like Spa pampered or whatever and my guy
knows that but I also make sure that
nothing that I'm doing to beautify
myself gets in the way of being an
active mom you know being able to cook
or clean or wash or do you know whatever
I just think the long fingernails in my
opinion it's kind of nasty because it's
not hygienic
um and then look at that and Kevin has
been known to say you know if certain
body parts are not up to par you know
you can you know draw your own
conclusions but yeah I just you know
I don't know man that I respect that has
been like look at those talents
um
um I did put don't be an idiot okay
please clarify so okay
in my family now I don't know this is
just I would just say where I'm from
they won't date like the women
can't be dumb of course so and a lot of
times like my brother wouldn't date
girls because they were education majors
and he got like a lot of our education
Majors were dumb because it's an easy
one yeah and and there's certain like
Majors that even from the women are a
bit looked down upon and it's not to say
there aren't smart teachers but there's
actually a study and you know
um teachers have a standard deviation
lower IQ than the rest of the population
actually yeah this is Thomas sowell's
book them the decline in dogma of
American Education if anyone's wondering
where to find that stat it's somewhere
in the book um I can't tell you the page
but yeah so
um okay so much for the substitute
teacher
but
um so like my there would just be
certain things my brothers like would
not date and it's like if you're gonna
do if you're gonna have no education or
career it's not a bad thing but you have
to have like
skills to back it up and it's very
important to the men like they don't
want a dumb woman raising their kids no
absolutely not I mean I agree you need
to be informed you don't have to know
everything about everything but I think
one thing that would serve like if you
are
um a little bit underperforming
academically and we know men don't care
about our degrees and all that but if
you do need to pick an area of study
study what he does be able to
communicate in his language let's say
I'm with somebody who's into real estate
I know nothing about real estate I have
a chemistry degree I'm like a you know
tech and and
stem person but I try to at least
understand you know buying a property
and hiring a team and doing that kind of
work that's not my natural area but it
shows a dedication to kind of get on his
program and at least be useful to him
because that's the language that he
speaks in that's the world where he
lives and breathes
creature
um they want a girl with a fitness
routine because they also look at like
your eating habits yeah so a guy might
see that you're thin when you're young
but if you're eating all this stuff they
kind of think this might not be this
much longer so guys look at like your
Fitness routine yeah
um good with kids of course
um knows how to cook having your own
recipe this is a bonus I forgot to put
on here ability to learn I actually
think that or not ability
to follow like coachable coachable is
huge because like guys will Overlook a
lot if they feel like they can train you
either you're willing to be trained so
maybe you can't cook but you're willing
to learn it's like
mental I met my brother say like it was
absolutely horrible the meal she cooked
but I was just they were so I was so
like it was so sweet of her to like
learn this recipe or whatever absolutely
and that one ties back to what you had
about not being a majestic creature
because I don't want to blow past that
because I struggle with you know
um making healthy choices all the time I
know a big part of it was the stress
from you know working the way that I was
working but I take full responsibility
for what I put in my mouth but to your
point men really love when you try even
if you're not there yet you know we
talked in the beginning about I've lost
a lot of weight but I have a ways to go
and I get so much credit for basically
doing what I say I'm going to do and
every day make making incremental
progress
um so yeah that goes along with that
Fitness routine and
um you know being coachable and
teachable you may not get it right but
if you're making a good faith effort
that goes a long way with men I'll tell
you my brother's engaged and the girl
he's engaged to she's an engineer okay
so she's smart she makes a lot of money
doing that
um
and she went to culinary school for fun
oh that's a dream of mine
he's like there's nothing I mean she's
talked to him maybe I'll open a
restaurant or something I don't know but
I was like she literally just went to
culinary school just to you know cook
for him yeah I mean for me and the way
that I was raised my mom is a retired hi
Mom home science teacher formerly home
economic so we talked about this
yesterday I just thought it was normal
but it's okay if you didn't grow up
cooking and doing laundry and cleaning
the house you can learn it and it's one
of those things like I never understood
it but you eat every day so why wouldn't
you cook every day but I know that's me
but at least trying and making some
shortcuts where you need to I think it
goes a long way it's it's a way that we
show love that's what we've done for
hundreds of years thousands of years
could you talk about okay because this
confuses me okay oh my gosh this
confuses me femininity
because a lot of times when women use it
it's so Broad
and there's never any real concrete like
definition of it that that I've seen and
then I see all these femininity coaches
that just say get in your feminine
energy and I'm just thinking what the
heck does that mean and I sort of
understand what they're saying but a lot
of times the way it translates to me
just the way I think is a lot of them
doing nothing and then saying they did
something ooh so it's like a lot of
women will like that coach femininity
will be these masculine women that are
clearly masculine like I can see it like
I'm talking to you I'm talking it'll be
like these girls that come on the show
they don't cook they don't do any of the
tradition but they're just in their
feminine energy
and they might say that they cook but
you can just tell when a woman talks
about cooking if she actually Cooks
because a girl that actually Cooks will
give you more detail and like a girl
that doesn't will say like like very
broad oh I cook this or maybe like some
rest recipe she's seen her mom because
you can just tell so like what is
femininity how do you improve it
yeah what what actually is femininity
and what are that like how specifically
do you improve it you know this one it's
interesting that you say that we
actually talked about this on my last
Wives Club episode that's the other
Channel that I have but femininity is
one of those things where
there is a dictionary definition and I
looked it up but it's also one of those
things it's a little bit elusive because
it's hard to Define but you know it when
you see it right however there are a lot
of buzzwords going on right now we have
that soft life era but it's not
something that you put on it's who you
are especially when you're tested so you
remember when we talked about like I
know that
I struggle sometimes with tough topics
and so I have to remove myself get it
together and come back because I don't
want to have you know an emotional
response those are the times when you
have an opportunity to be you know
masculine and you choose not to
consistently so for me it's so good Who
You Are
when you're tested okay right so when
the kids are hungry and they're pulling
at your skirt and they're like Mommy can
we eat if them kids is probably not the
most feminine response right so you know
we can work on that but yes it's it's a
buzzword that you know if people say but
they don't do then they're not feminine
because if you're truly feminine I don't
have to tell you that I'm feminine you
would pick up on that right so to me and
the dictionary definition is something
about having the qualities or the
characteristics of a woman and when we
had our last episode on the Wives Club I
said you know for me I really have been
intentional about studying men because I
am a boy mom you grew up between
Brothers watching how they act and doing
the opposite so if they come into a room
and they're all loud I bring my volume
down I slow down and I'm mindful of my
gestures if they take up a lot of space
if they're just like heavy you know
stomping around then I'm like oh okay
and it is something that I had to learn
and we talked about this a little bit
yesterday with co-ed schools and just
kind of like being around boys or any
environment that you're in you're gonna
pick up on that whether it's the
corporate or whether it's girlfriends
that you know are a little bit messy or
whatnot so to answer your questions so
that I clearly communicate you know
being feminine is
the opposite of a man and I know things
have gotten Blended but I also believe
being feminine is being consistent and
being feminine is
um you know like I said when you're
tested when it's difficult but you still
maintain so how do you improve on that
um you seek it out and you get coaching
and you act on that coaching like I
shared with you I learned that I used to
have really masculine gestures I was a
little bit all over the place so you'll
see me kind of put my hands down and
clasp them together because I'm being
mindful of okay I want to be a little
bit more
um delicate and refined I notice when I
get loud I'll catch myself and I'll
lower my volume these are just things
that I've had to work on for other
people and I'm not joking it could be
swearing for you swearing wasn't an
issue for me but being loud was it could
be uh being gracious and generous to
people like I smile a lot and I'm
Pleasant it might be an area that
someone else has to work on because they
want to say you know what that's them
kids or whatever so being mindful
finding out the areas where you're
lacking because there are different ways
to be feminine there are different types
of it
um these are all things that I've
studied again for me it's an area that I
could kind of nerd out in but I think
what you said about taking one thing at
a time just at knowing it Kevin always
used to say self-awareness right not
saying I'm a 10 I'm average I know that
so I try to really over perform in other
areas and so you know a little bit
long-winded answer but I would just like
to encourage anyone that you can
definitely get better if it's something
that's important to you and femininity
is what men respond to because they
don't want somebody that reminds them of
themselves
do not be a feminist
I read this that these under the wrong
one
I'm gonna move this okay
I might have to ask you to Define that
one because that how feminist uh
definition it's changed and a lot of
times people hang what they want
something to mean on a certain word and
even things that might have started off
a little Noble now there's
wow feminists
someone that wants women that believes
women are better than men and say they
say it's equality I was going to say
because what I've heard is people say
we're equal you don't want women and men
to be equal and in a way that that's
part of the problem is they think men
and women are equal so that one they
they think men and women are equal which
we're not we're different yeah and on
top of that they also think that women
are better than men and they might not
say that in the definition but you could
certainly see it by the you know the
things they say like men are trash yeah
um the the way feminists act in the
media and the issues that they support
that are often at the expense of men so
for example me too
you know it might have had good
intentions but what are the outcome
um so yeah that's that's what I would
say don't don't be a feminist yeah that
one so that one's a hard one as a boy
mom sometimes it's a visceral reaction
that I get because that Mama Bear kind
of comes up and you know I have heard
that I have heard women that I have
worked with basically say men are stupid
um you know you only need one parent you
don't need you know a man as long as
you've gotten one good parent and I
think that is it's so detrimental but
these are going to be the same people
that kind of wish they had a man when
times get hard in my opinion
that's the saddest thing where they
don't think
like I think going to a sperm bank and
just having a kid is cry I know someone
that did that she uh she she was
morbidly obese
she was in her 40s and she had twins
and and one of the twins came out like
their foot was messed up because and I
just remember thinking this this was a
horrible idea why didn't you just get
married yeah and I know this one is a
really touchy one for a lot of people
but we talked about this yesterday and
I'm just gonna say I think inherently
it's selfish because I want a child you
have to think about what life are you
creating for this child and you know
children get their identity from their
father you know I see it now we talked
about this yesterday I'm so glad that I
co-parent even though the marriage ended
my youngest is in boarding school he
goes to military school and my oldest
lives with his dad pretty much he comes
to visit me because at 15 he I mean he
has his he had his dad the whole time
but it is so important and um you know I
know people make decisions for what they
want but you know we talked about this
yesterday even if I would have loved to
um get remarried and have more children
I don't get what I want just because I
want it there are children that are
already here and my responsibility is to
finish what I started and if I'm so
fortunate to get married again and live
out my golden years then that is what I
get that is the hardest thing at times
like as women and I've even struggled
with this like understanding it's his
plan it's not your plan and so if he
wants to do it we can do it if not you
know yeah I got that yeah I mean like I
said you know we had two boys back to
back and I asked my husband at the time
I said do you want to try for a girl do
you want three if he had said yes we
would have you know I would have been a
mom of three but he said no I just think
discounting men is is first of all this
is a human being that has you know
feelings and emotions and you know I
just as a mom this is a tough one for me
because I see what's out there and you
know I want I want everybody to win but
you know I do feel very strongly about
just completely discounting men just
because because if the tables were
turned
yeah okay I decided I'm just tired of
these words yes it's from the show
partner
horoscope signs looking for a connection
energy
trauma toxic masculinity my truth oh my
gosh healing my narcissistic
ex-boyfriend my abusive ex-boyfriend a
great accusation with no evidence okay
I'm glad you said don't don't judge
um yeah but manifesting equals I do I
want to work but I want to do no work
and get the outcome as a woman we know
what your gender is I did too much and I
let him walk all over me equals I like
cheaters and toxic men and I will choose
them and be toxic as well and not admit
that I had any part to play except quote
unquote giving too much generational
trauma I make the same mistakes that my
parents make and I'm too dumb to learn
from their mistakes and instead I will
make the same mistakes but blame it on
them in my feminine energy men always
stare and approach me I will be
submissive for the right man men are
trash equals I take no accountability
for the negative part that I play or any
women play in our relationships he needs
to make six figures equals I have no
emphasis on character I don't need a man
but I want a man my ring needs to cost
this much Financial abuse I became
feminine I need a man to maintain me we
need to Vibe I feel like I am
traditional when I am single
oh my goodness are these quotes from
your show yeah just like talking to
girls okay almost all of them I
understand help me understand since we
were just talking about femininity I
became feminine because you can improve
you know I I understand where you're
coming from I may I may walk back this
one okay however I find that most of the
time when women say it it equals I did
no real work I made no real changes but
I say I am feminine oh just like poof
okay yeah I just I became feminine and
then I'll like break it down and I'll be
like okay so what what did you do to
become or they'll say I was Modern and I
became traditional so I'll say well what
did you do to become those things and
they'll have like
just word salad yeah no and no real
answers like you know if you're gonna
say I became look what you said was a
real answer I worked on lowering my
voice I used to do masculine manner
those are real answers and that actually
clarified
that actually clarified
you don't have to copy it even better
this is better this is something better
it's important to me but yeah I mean
again no you actually clarified a lot of
things that um like I honestly was so
confused when I heard it because I just
heard so much like fluff and garbage and
even like girls that I know that studied
femininity and would say I became
feminine had no real answers yeah and
then they would say oh I became feminine
but you're screaming at your your guy
how did you become feminine if you're
screaming at him right if you have that
response then you still have some work
to do because if you ask these same
women how did you get your cosmetology
license oh I had to study this amount I
had to take these mini classes I had to
do these many hours how did you become a
dentist how did you pick anything we can
walk you through all of the things that
we do to get what we want and goal of
you know how you show up in a
relationship requires just as much work
if not more and it's okay I'm actually
kind of proud to say you know I have had
to do a lot of work to go from that 50
50 mindset to being more of a support
system and I haven't arrived I still
have work to do but I've gotten a lot
better so
so is there any phrases we should add to
here that you've heard oh goodness so
you had the the trauma and the energy
um toxic let me know in the chat guys if
there's anything we missed that we need
to add
um
what Manish have you heard that one no
oh but I'll add it yeah
it's basically describing masculine
Behavior like there's something wrong
with it and it's not better or worse we
are different we're equally valued but
we are not equal and I think that's a
beautiful thing
I thought of another I need like I need
there's some phrase that girls use when
they won't be led by a guy and they're
like oh well I need the right man to
like I'll be submissive for the right
man I will be submissive for the right
man because
I in a way I understand where they're
coming I was gonna say yeah this one I
could unpack a little bit too but at the
same time that equals
I choose right like they put the
accountability on them like oh he didn't
lead me when it's like you picked him
that's true we have to be responsible
for our choices I think
yes I am submissive by Nature if there
are men around me like there's so even
if you're not my man there are some ways
that I do submit I don't talk over men I
don't
um try to compete with men I don't
um
uh brag or lead with my accomplishments
uh because those things are very
masculine traits now if you ask me I'm
going to respond you ask me a direct
question I'll give you a direct answer
but there are ways that I submit to my
man that I don't to other men but that's
the only thing that I wanted to to
clarify on that but if you're a
submissive person then if you're a
submissive woman then you're just a
submissive woman you know I think about
my mom you know even her son my brother
if he says mom no we're going to get you
this you know the doctor says you need
to do this so you need to do that that's
her son she says okay Phil and so like I
I see that so it's just realizing like
this is a man who loves you and and you
know is looking out for you so yeah I
don't yeah I won't be submissive for
that right yeah I think you should be
submissive in relationship to your man
but um
I think almost you know I just believe
in respecting them so what phrase is to
add to our vocabulary I trust you I
support you whatever you say baby thank
you I have your back I'm making blank
for dinner tonight honey I believe or I
think what can I do to help you how can
I help what else should we add
I'm proud of you
um
do we have I believe in you
um what are all the things that I say to
my man I'm gonna get a little bit of
vulnerable here
um I couldn't do this without you I need
you
um I trust you
I love you
um I desire you
I miss you
I care about you
um
I want you
these are great
thank you it's this yeah so we're gonna
get rid of these
[Music]
and we're gonna go to this
okay
what do you think guys oh I'm so glad
I'm glad it worked out this way is that
a good one oh who hurt you they want to
add to this yes Lord who hasn't been
hurt good grief everybody's got a story
that can make you cry
that's true yeah that's true they always
say that to me who hurt you yeah that's
what they you know what they say oh my
gosh oh no they say that I I am I body
shame because my ex left me for a fat
girl that's what they say the story they
say
it's not true but that's what they like
that's what they say they're like oh she
just hates us
but then yeah
yeah so you know
yeah so they'll be like oh to hear you
I'm just like leave me alone yeah I mean
if you've lived life or any moment of
time you've got heartbreaking story so
like miss me with that one I admire you
I love that mm-hmm
I admire you
it's just so important I just feel
better hearing them and saying them
and one thing while you're looking I
would just offer if you can't say this
to your man
you have the wrong man and that's okay
move towards somebody that you can say
this to submission is not an eating
submission is not an issue when you have
a man that you admire and trust and
respect and love and believe in it's
like whatever you say yeah but but it's
like we we don't a lot of times like we
can't even admit there's a problem yeah
you got to start with that yeah you have
to start with that
um what is the biggest problem that you
would say that we're blinded to
I would say there's a lot of women that
think that they're traditional and
they're not so I would say there's a lot
of women that say they're traditional
and genuinely go through life thinking
they're traditional because maybe their
parents were they watched it but they
have no traditional skills
agreed and it goes back to that other
list that we had the wife resume you
know just like a job right it gets
really personal when we talk about
relationships but even when you're going
for a job you have your resume of your
strengths the thing that the things that
you're good at and when you go apply for
a job they're going to look at that and
they're going to compare it to the job
description and if I'm looking for
someone who cooks five nights a week and
you don't then it's not a good match you
know if I'm looking for someone who's
ready to you know be a stay-at-home mom
or whatever it is and you want to work
60 hours a week then it's not a good
match so you know the traditional values
and I'm a very traditional person but I
accept and I understand that that
doesn't apply to everyone Circle back to
the types of marriages if you're
marrying somebody let's say I knew a
family member of mine got married and
they lived apart they lived in different
states because someone was wrapping up
like a doctoral program so twice a month
one of the the other couple would fly
you know back and that that worked for
them so I'm not saying there's only one
way that'll work but the man that you're
interested in what are his expectations
and does it match with what you bring to
the table Yeah that's the other thing I
would say that women are delusional
about is like we often think we bring
more than we do oh absolutely and we
don't realize like a lot of people say
that I'm like hating on women when I say
we bring less to the table than ever
before but I just think it's honest yeah
I think what we have now as
accomplishments are more than what like
my mom and women of other Generations
have however it's not a value to a man
yes so the fact that I pay my mortgage
have a car take vacations come to see
Pearl all of that is great for me but if
I'm looking for a man or caught myself
if I want to belong to a man and he's
looking looking for someone who is
useful to him
I would just advise that we don't lead
with those things because basically it
says me me me I I I so he's like well
what do I need you for
mm-hmm
this is so I feel like you're like
putting us on game this is so helpful oh
well honestly you know I mean Kevin is
here and you know shout out to The
Godfather
um you know we talked about this
yesterday I actually booked a session
you know with him and you know we can
talk about you know other things but I
always got convicted whenever I would
hear Kevin Samuel say where are the
older women to teach the young because I
I love the fact that you're soaking it
up and it's really a blessing to me but
I remember trying to talk to women in my
peer group whether it was corporate or
whatever and I would try to have these
conversations and oh the way I was
shouted down so the same kind of
backlash that you have publicly I had
privately and so you know I'm just the
type I'm not gonna go 12 rounds with you
so I just kind of okay I'm on my
business being my cul-de-sac Live My
Little Life cook my meals and just be
left alone but I didn't have that
community so I created that community so
it's important
that sounds great
great really yeah thank you like I think
you're great I said she's a natural-born
YouTuber guys she's gonna she's gonna do
big things on YouTube
gracious thank you from your